the present decision came with no
warning Jeff Pegues is here with the
reaction from inside the FBI and the
events that led to commis firing
Jeff good morning good morning commis
dismissal stunned officials at the FBI
but looking back there were some very
public signs of a rift on several
occasions over the last several weeks
director Comey defied President Trump on
the Russia investigation you're stuck
with me for about another six and a half
years James commis dismissal sent
shockwaves through the FBI current and
former FBI officials told CBS News
everyone is stunned this will do damage
to the FBI that will take years to
recover from one recently retired
official said anyone under 50 is working
on their resume commis firing raises
questions about what's next for the
FBI's counterintelligence investigation
into potential connections between the
Trump campaign and Russia though an
investigation began last July Comey
publicly acknowledged it for the first
time in March this will also include an
assessment of whether any crimes were
committed during the hearing Comey said
he had no evidence to support the
president's claims that Trump Tower was
under surveillance during the Obama
administration the FBI and the
Department of Justice have no
information to support those tweets
Attorney General Jeff Sessions
recommendation to fire Comey comes after
sessions recused himself from the Russia
investigation when it was revealed he
had previously undisclosed conversations
with Russia's ambassador I should have
slowed down and said but I did meet one
Russian official in recent weeks federal
prosecutors have issued grand jury
subpoenas to Associates of former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
Flynn is one of several Trump campaign
representatives under scrutiny by the
FBI I thought it was very important to
call out what the Russians were trying
to do with our election last Wednesday
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
Comey said when it came to his
investigations he had no regrets the
only thing I regret is it may be
answering the phone when they called to
recruit me to be FBI director and I was
living happily in Connecticut earlier
Tuesday the FBI walked back miss
statements made during recent testimony
just last week on Capitol Hill Comey
said Clinton aide
Abidine forwarded hundreds of thousands
of government emails to a computer she
shared with her husband Anthony Weiner
the FBI acknowledged that was not
accurate and the number of forwarded
emails was far smaller Comey was fired
later on in the day the deputy Andrew
McCabe is now in charge in fact it was
just like a dozen emails right exactly
exactly
any word on who will replace Comey no
you know obviously we know that McCabe
now takes over but will that be a
short-term long without fix we'll have
to see if the I divide you in some ways
it is and part of that is the result of
what happened with the Clinton email
server investigation but still director
Comey was widely respected for the most
part Jeff thank you